leute ihr habt wirklich mein Postfach
überflutet mit dem Diamond painting
Adventskalender das einzige mal als ich
Diamond painting gemacht habe war auf
meinem asmr Kanal ansonsten weiß ich
nicht woher dieser Hype
kommt erster Anblick uh schön
weihnachtlich und jetzt machen wir das
Baby auf oh mein Gott der sieht ja so
cute aus also auch extrem kitschig aber
auf diese wirklich gute Art kitschig auf
diese es kribbelt in meinem Bauch und
ich habe Kindheitserinnerung kitschig es
kribbelt in meinem
Bauch ich habe einfach schon viel zu
viele Kalender ausgepackt ich sag e wie
es ist optisch sehr schön ich habe
natürlich wieder eine zweite Kamera
hallo weil ich mal ganz stark vermute
dass wir heute Diamond painting machen
und ob wir damit richtig liegen finden
wir jetzt heraus wir fangen an mit tüche
Nummer 1 Diamond painting ach so oh mein
was ist denn los es ist sehr früh ich
habe noch nie so früh gedreht bevor ich
jetzt zu oft Diamond painting oder
pigmondo sage ich glaube das Ding ist
von P ja picmondo dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle zusammen
dieses Videos nicht
gesponsert ich zieh das auch nach se
Wochen noch durch irgendwas gab's noch
der Preis er ist ausverkauft und wir
haben gerade mal Anfang November also da
steht
19995 durchgestrichen
12997 wahrscheinlich ist das der waren
Wert ich habe mich schon gewundert als
ihr mein Postfach so folge Spam hab
damit ist Diamond painting so ein
krasses Ding ich habe vor zwei Jahren
erst so mal nach Zahlen bisschen für
mich entdeckt ich weiß rentnerhobby aber
irgendwie ist sehr beruhigend und beim
Diamond painting ja habe ich wie gesagt
ich habe mal so ein ganz kleines Bild
Halt gemacht machen alle Diamond
painting nur ich krieg das nicht mit
Nummer habe ich Diamond painting falsch
verstanden das ist washi tape klingt
komisch ist aber so mit Einhörnern und
Eiscreme und Torte und believe in
miracle und regenburen und Katzen und
pink pmondo was ist denn pigmondo für
eine Seite pmondo ist eine Seite ich
kann es auch nicht vorher das ist so ja
das so alles das Diamond painting das
mal nach Zahlen das Scratch painting
also so eine kreative Bastelseite malen
und basteln und ob wir jetzt mit Diamond
pendting anfangen können sehen wir wenn
das Licht angeht was soll das sein die
Diamond painting Provis unter euch
wissen natürlich sofort dass das
wahrscheinlich ein Tool ist was man fürs
Diamond painting benutzt also hier haben
wir so ein Bürstenkopf und da ist so
eine kleine Hand perfekt um einen Tisch
vorzubereiten ich möchte Diamond
painting machen bitte gib mir Diamond
painting Sachen tüchen Nummer 3 ich habe
mich so auf Diamond painting gefreut das
ist ein Schneemann ein Schneemann mit so
ein
Magnet ich weiß nicht wofür der sonst
gemacht ist kleiner Sidekick wir lassen
uns natürlich nicht beirren denn jetzt
kommt Diamond painting in Türchen Nummer
vi ja ja
ja in wirklich sehr unweihnachtlichen
Farben ich bin mal gespannt was einem
noch erwartet das sind halt so Quadrate
die Aussehen kleine Diamanten damit malt
man falls V Diamond painting noch nicht
drauf gekommen seid Nummer
5 ich ja ich habe das Gefühl ich sag
seit 10 Minuten nichts anderes Auer ja
hier haben wir ein Trichter es ist ein
Trichter wahrscheinlich den man braucht
um vielleicht
da irgendwie wieder was zu füllen das
ist doch langweilig gut wir machen mal
weiter es ist Nikolaus wir gehen zu
unserem Adventskalender und freuen uns
über also das erkennt ein Diamond
painting Profi ja sofort verschiedene
Größen von so aufpickern dass man halt
in einer extrem schnellen
Geschwindigkeit das so randingsen kann
nimmst du deine Diamonds klack machst du
sie da drauf mein Gott ist dieser
Adventskalender unspektakulär ich hoffe
die Diamond painting Community ist nicht
ganz so wie die KPOP
Community also wenn ich etwas sage was
euch nicht gefällt es tut mir leid ich
bin hier neu im Game okay ich wer schon
noch checken Bo Türchen Nummer 7 ist ein
riesengroßes Türchen das macht uns
Hoffnung der hält be wie bei diesem Aros
Spiel kennt ihr noch bei Disney Toy cl
spel genauso funktioniert dieser
Kalender da kann sich Paul Valentine mal
eine Scheibe von
abschneiden und an dem könnt ihr
erkennen was ich meine mit kitch aber
auch irgendwie schön aber auch kitch in
Nummer 7 befindet sich jawollo ein
pencutter stiftschneider was ist ich
weiß nicht ob diese Spitze da oben drauf
ein Produktionsfehler ist oder ob das
absichtlich so eine ganz kleine Spitze
ich glau Produktionsfehler und ich
verstehe nicht hier sind die Diamonds
hier sind sie rund dort sind sie
quadratisch gibt es verschiedene Arten
von Diamonds ja aber so guck mal das ist
do was ich erwartet habe weihnachtliche
Motive und dass man frech drauf los
Painten kann wir machen mal den
Tannenbaum hier okay okay das
ist das erinnert mich an die Kaugummis
die man immer so kaufen kann mir fällt
gerade auf ich habe für dieses Video
wahrscheinlich eine viel jüngere
Zielgruppe am Start deswegen hallo
Kinder heute machen wir Diamond painting
unser erstes Motiv ist ein Tannenbaum
den stellt man sich immer an Weihnachten
auf hier haben wir unsere komische
Klebemasse wo wir immer unseren Stift
reinstecken müssen damit wir so schön
Gummi dran haben dass das die Diamonds
schön aufhebt ah ja und das hier klebt
wir fangen mit den Sternen an me brauch
nicht nun nehmen wir unsere Klebemasse
und dann stecken wir da so schön unseren
Stift Rein und dann haben wir diese
Klebemasse vorne an unserem Stift ich
glaube das ist so wie es funktioniert
und dann geht's los richtig spektakulär
BAM ich erinnere mich dass es Spaß macht
oh mein Gott das war amazing wow oh von
Haar brauchen wir ganz viel eigentlich
ist das ja was was man in Ruhe machen
sollte oder wow bin ich entspannt
nein ich liebe es oh
bisschen Gumm ja noch leichter als mal
nach Zahlen gell noch zwei Stück habe
ich euch eentlich schon mal gesagt dass
ich meinen Job
[Musik]
liebe ah da ist es schon vorbei Bo ich
bin richtig wie in so
TRS ich weiß nicht wie ich gleich noch
die anderen Türchen
aufmach
so und jetzt haben wir die coolsten
Diamonds weil es literally Diamonds sind
Glitzersteine echte Rubine das ist ein
dicker Bub oh sehen die schön aus und
der
letzte oh mein Gott wisst ihr woran mich
das erinnert an die Swarowski
Sticker sind Sticker es ist sehr lustig
gerade dass es warowski auch geschafft
hat Sticker reinzumachen einzige
Unterschied swowski Sticker hab 50 €
gekostet
sind durchsichtig ja als Kind hätte ich
das geliebt ist das cool oh mein Gott ja
wo klebe ich den jetzt drauf ist die
Frage ich kleb es auf mein Laptop ich we
abkriegt oh schön dann kann oh das füht
sich voll gut an dann weiß ich immer
dass jetzt gerade Weihnachten ist ich
hoffe man kriegt den ab wenn nicht dann
wäre das sehr
blöd ich muss mal ganz kurz wach werden
dieses Diamond painting hat mich gerade
richtig
eingeschläfert
auf Türchen Nummer
8 Grinder liebe Kinder mama was ist ein
gr es ist ein
Grinder oh mein
Gott was z hle soll sonst sein ich habe
keine Ahnung wofür man das in der
diaming painting world benutzen würde
zum nächsten Türchen long
Hal stop boah Türchen Nummer ne9 ist
voll gepackt ich sag euch Türchen Nummer
9 ist das beste Türchen Beweisstück ah
guckt mal was hier alles drin ist jetzt
kriegen wir wieder eine zweite Schale ah
dann können wir auch mehrere Farben
haben und zweimal Gummi und Diamonds nur
in der glitzi Edition die sind zum
Tannenbaum aufhängen ich weiß e leute
das ist der Swarowski Kalender in
bezahlbar das sind
wow egal hat auf jeden Fall Anhänger das
Rentier will ich
machen also die Diamond painting
Community ist wirklich eine ganz
spezielle
Community oh no viel zu viele abziehen
und drauf los
Painten ist das ein toller
Spaß
schon deprimierend wenn man es daneben
klebt man muss echt konzentriert
bleiben das ist auch auf der Rückseite
ich kann es nicht fassen leute das ist
auch auf der
Rückseite
ich fü mal was von meinem gliber hier
nach frisch aufgefüllt geht's weiter hey
Vanessa teste doch mal den Diamond
painting Adventskalender das ist so
spannt dir dabei zuzugucken wie du
Diamond painting
[Musik]
machst brauch e ich hoffe die sind nicht
abgezählt man darf bloß kein
verlieren
oh mein Gott da das lang
[Musik]
ey
es ist fertig ich habe dafür eine Stunde
gebraucht eine Stunde aber man kann
sagen es sieht jetzt richtig cool
aus nice irgendwann war ich nur noch wie
so ein Tunnel und war so Diamond Diamond
Diamond der beruch war mir z monotom ich
habe nichts mehr Gefühl das ist aber sau
gut ich habe auch an nichts gedacht
meine einzigen Gedanken waren Diamond
Diamond die moderne Art zu meditieren
meditieren ist nämlich sehr schwer an
nichts zu denken ist die höchste Kunst
und ohne Übung ist es so
schwer aber hiermit nicht hiermit geht's
super leicht was machen wir jetzt ich
pack diesen Kalender gefühlt seit zwei
Stunden aus und bin bei Türchen Nummer
8 noch mehr Magneten oh mein gott sieht
das cute aus aber wofür das sind so
Boxen mit so Motiven drin die haben
wieder so ein Magnet dran so macht ihr
aus jedem Pulli einen Weihnachts
[Musik]
Pulli h Christmas Sweater Nummer 11 oh
bitte nicht noch mal Diamond painting
bitte gib mir Diamond painting Sachen
die verstehe ich aber nicht jetzt sind
da random noch mal grün und orange drin
und wir hatten also ist das so zum
Freestyle Diamond painting Halbzeit
großes Paket großes Paket Türchen Nummer
12 und da drin oh ja oh super oh super
oh oh mein Gott ja das kann ich nicht
machen das ist leider nicht drin ne wie
cool
oh hier ist einmal das standardequipment
drin mit dem Pen mit der Schale und zwei
Herzen ah ja das Gummizeug Tüten um die
Diamanten da reinzupacken wenn man sie
benutzt hat ganz viele Diamonds mit auch
so ultra special Farben uh die sehen ja
cute aus und quadratisch ah ja hier
macht das mehr bei diesem Motiv macht
dieses mehrere auf einmal kleben
natürlich Sinn hier sind die alle direkt
nebeneinander da kann man reinrödeln ne
da ballert man dann fünf auf einmal das
Motiv ist so
süß ich bin Diamond painting Fan versteh
nicht was macht man dann mit dem Rand
macht man da ein paspatout drüber
wahrscheinlich ne wenn man sich das
einrahmen möchte tolles Türchen Nummer
12 riesengroßer Spaß so Nummer
13 das ist dieses Gummi was man sich in
diese Spitze macht das war aber
literally im Türchen vorher drin also ja
ich verstehe dass man das vielleicht zum
Nachfüllen viel brauch aber direkt
dahinter dann nur das Nummer
14 ja ich meine das ist Zeug das braucht
man für Diamond painting ein stickerheft
wo man wahrscheinlich auf die Tüten die
man ein Türchen vorher bekommen hat die
so beschriften kann aber dann würde ich
das lieber so als eintürchen machen und
nicht das eine so vollballern mit Zeug
weiß nicht dieser Kalender ist ein Auf
und Ab der Gefühle Nummer
15 tolle Farben sage ich ja gar nichts
dagegen ne die glitzern sogar schön aber
was haben die jetzt denn damit zu tun
ist das wirklich Freestyle Diamond
painting
16 irgendwann ist gut mit denen ich habe
schon vier oder fünf Motive jetzt
bekomme ich auch noch diese zum
Aufhängen mit den noch mal vier Stück
davon und mit noch mal die saanne und
natürlich den Diamonds den passenden
werde ich auch nicht machen bitte gib
mir Diamond painting Sachen 17 random
einfach nur weiße Diamonds ist ist so
ein Ding bei der Diamond Community das
weiß immer fehlt oder man es verliert
oder ist das irgendwie eine Sammlung ich
lass mich mal noch überraschen weil
diese random Diamonds die machen für
mich noch gar keinen Sinn
18 also jetzt hat man wirklich genug
Stifte am Anfang habe ich schon ein
bekommen dann habe ich zwischendurch
noch in diesem Set eins gekriegt und
jetzt kommt aber der das ist der Profi
Stift ja mann so kann man es viel besser
greifen 19 ist wieder groß
yay na natürlich wieder ein großes Motiv
ich hab es doch ich hab es doch geahnt
ich habe es doch geahnt eine Freestyle
Matte ohne Motiv hier kann man wirklich
Diamond Painten was man will gerade so
zur Weihnachtszeit wenn ich vielleicht
selber ein Weihnachtsmotiv machen möchte
was will ich dann mit diesen Farben das
sind Neonfarben wir sind in den 20ern
angekommen ja also ich dachte ich habe
wieder das gleiche gekriegt aber nein
das sind quadratisch weiße Diamonds das
sind runde
21 ehrlich ich weiß es nicht ja man
könnte diese Diamonds da rein machen
aber dafür hat man no auch diese Tütchen
bekommen die ein bisschen mehr Sinn
machen oder das macht natürlich auch
Sinn und sie sind wie eine andere Form
von diesen großen wo die Magnete drin
waren aber hier ist nichts drin Nummer
22 oh mensch jetzt hat man schon seine
Freestyle Matte bekommen und dann kommen
da noch Farben ja blöd ne da weiß man
auch nicht wie man das Sortieren soll
ich liebe dieses Holo Schimmer auf den
Stein das vorletzte Türchen Türchen
Nummer
23 ist eine Spitze für was für nichts
was wir hier haben ist so eine Spitze
zum ranchrauben warum ist da kein Stiel
dran warum kann ich das nicht greifen
warum ist es nicht einfach ein ganz
normaler Stift warum ist es ein Aufsatz
für was ist es ein Aufsatz ich habe
nichts wo ich das drauf setzen kann ich
hoffe dieses Rätsel wird jetzt in
Türchen Nummer 24 gelöst hey und falls
ihr denkt aber was kriegen wir denn aus
dieser ganzen Geschichte natürlich das
pinke bunte
Einhorn cute Cupcake washi
tape
das geht hier in diese Box rein denn da
sind alle Produkte drin die ich aus den
Adventskalendern rausgeholt hab und was
mache ich mit diesen Produkten ich
verlose sie auf Instagram ungefähr Mitte
November wird es eine Verlosung auf
meinem Instagram Account geben und dort
könnt ihr dann mitmachen und dann
vielleicht einen original malf
Adventskalender gewinnen also original
ne und jetzt gehen wir zu unserem
Adventskalender es ist der 24 es ist
Christmas Christmas in my heart meine
Finger tun schon weh vom Diamond
painting und jetzt gibt's eine
ordentliche
Bescherung auf jeden Fall etwas zu tun
über die Weihnachtsfeiertage denkt ja
immer man macht da viel okay nee ich bin
raus sorry was war denn das eben gerade
okay also schön wir haben hier ein
tolles Motiv ein Elch die Diamonds dafür
natürlich braucht man weil das wieder
hier komplett ausartet natürlich Tüten
jetzt bekommen wir noch mal so ein Set
wo ich mir denke wir haben doch eins und
jetzt kommt das Highlight uh wir kriegen
den profistab was ist an diesem
profistab dran diese gottverdammte
Spitze ist das eine ersatzspitze ich
glaub das ist eine ersatzspitze das ist
eine ersatzspitze okay ersatzspitze
warum ist sie ein Türchen aber dieser
Stift das sieht danach aus dass man sehr
viel Diamond painting machen aber so
schön ist doch do brauchen wir ein Fazit
ne ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es echt
nicht nee das Ding ist washi tape hat
mich komplett verwirrt manche Türchen
haben mich komplett verwirrt z.B haben
wir also
Tier dieses Türchen was soll das das
sind runde Diamonds als einzige die man
einfach so bekommen hat auf dieser
Fläche sind Quadrate drauf und alle
anderen die man bekommen hat sind
quadratisch außer die diese ersatzspitze
diese Herzen die man eh schon zweimal
bekommen hat in diesem Set und das washi
tape diesen kleinen Besen habe ich
mittlerweile verstanden die Diamonds
sind wirklich schwer von A nach B zu
kriegen wenn ich einmal Diamond painting
machen wollen würde dann würde ich mir
lieber ein Bild kaufen und dieses
Diamond painting machen das hier ist
wirklich für Diamond painting ultra Fans
aber wenn du Diamond painting ultra Fan
bist hast du wahrscheinlich schon diese
Sachen deswegen ist es für mich sehr
schwer zu verstehen warum man diesen
Adventskalender kaufen sollen würde als
ist das auch
gut ich weiß es nicht es sind 129 € man
muss schon wirklich richtig Bock drauf
haben voll nervös er ist nicht schlecht
aber er ist auch jetzt nicht überragend
gut aber ich muss sagen Diamond pending
ist wirklich sehr entspannt und ich kann
mir vorstellen das jetzt auch noch mal
zu machen auf camera ich sage euch jetzt
nicht ich ich bin hin und her gerissen
ich finde den Kalender irgendwie gut
irgendwie auch nicht schreibt mir gerne
eure Meinung in die Kommentare
vielleicht sind da ja ein paar Diamond
painting Profis die ein bisschen mehr
dazu sagen können und ansonsten sehen
wir uns dann das nächste Mal
wieder